ce local vide en face du métro outremont
va le rester encore un peu résultat de
pressions populaires une pétition
de 15 cents soixante et un ans de risque
d'un peuplement
qui s'inquiétaient de voir une
succursale de la société québécoise du
cannabis ouvrir ses portes trop près
selon eux des écoles du quartier même si
la distance de 150 mètres imposée par la
loi était respectée il réclamait que
l'arrondissement s'élèvent contre la
escudé c'est ça soutient les valeurs
familiales du quartier si c'est pour la
sécurité des enfants ce serait une bonne
idée peut-être passé parlent aussi mais
y'a plein écoles secondaires primaire je
pense que c'est pas là mais le meilleur
endroit pour mettre une excuse et c'est
l'argument de la prévention pour cette
résidente qui habitent dans le secteur
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années il
est contestable ce que j'en pense c'est
que vivent sur l'avenue van horne juste
en face du palais stamm du côté de la
rue elle je vais vous dire que j'en vois
qui
dans le quartier
il ya aussi derrière une réflexion sur
l'impact en termes de qualité de vie car
outremont est un arrondissement sans
barre sans saq et donc sans vente de
cannabis pour l'instant je ne
sais pas peut-être les quartiers va
changer à l'eau à montréal
parfois
sable l'arrondissement a tranché pas de
prohibition mais un resserrement des
critères le bail a été annulé et cela
réduit fortement la zone où pourrait
s'ouvrir une excuse et c'est pour cette
spécialiste en éthique et politique de
santé publique ces ajustements peuvent
avoir des conséquences alors on peut
même se poser la question est ce qu
éventuellement ça va pas entraîner
d'autres quartiers à faire de même puis
éventuellement peut-être le gouvernement
à revoir sa norme c'est effectivement on
se rend compte qu'elle correspond moins
aux désirs des citoyens puis peut-être à
des enjeux de santé publique outremont
n'est pas le seul endroit où la escudé
s'est a eu des bâtons dans les roues
autre déboire à saint léonard
vente est totalement interdites depuis
2010 9 l'état la route était très
content c'était moyen d'ajustement d'une
époque banaliser cette
substance et aucune action en justice
contre l'arrondissement ne sera engagée
par la spdc verdun la chine et le
sud-ouest ont tous dit non à un certain
moment à une succursale tandis qu'en
joue à fortement restreint la zone
d'implantation possibles oui on peut se
poser des questions à savoir s'en va pas
tomber avec une santé publique à la
pièce qui peut être à géométrie variable
même division dans l'arrondissement
villeray saint michel parc extension ou
une succursale s'apprête à ouvrir au
métro jarry une station de transit pour
les jeunes de l'école secondaire georges
vanier située à environ 500 mètres de là
on est sept les jeunes importance mais
quand les autres tout près c'est une
tentation beaucoup de gens sont d'accord
pour dire que faut évoluer un peu dans
nos mentalités
l'arrondissement assure n'avoir reçu
aucune plainte citoyenne la escudé s'est
précise n'avoir subi une annulation de
bike à trois reprises à montréal et
c'est la première fois que cela survient
après des pressions citoyenne ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal